There's one last set of concepts I'd
like to cover before we move into some
actual programming and this is ACID.
Now again, like many of the concepts
in this lecture this is a very,
very broad topic and we're just
barely going to scratch the surface.
But I want you to be familiar with these
concepts because this is the type of
language we'll be using when
we're building our system.
So, ACID, this stands for,
A for atomicity,
C for consistency, I for
isolation, and D for durability.
Atomicity refers to the notion that
all parts of a transaction succeed or
fail together, Now,
we haven't talked about transactions.
But these are basically
just a group of statements.
So if we were updating our database
which is actually not something
we spent much time on.
There maybe the case where
updating two tables at once or
updating multiple rows in our database
together, in one cohesive unit.
For example, if for
working from the written example if we
had a link table and user's table and
somebody upvoted on the link and
that increases the user's reputation.
In that increase
the score of the link and
also increase
the reputation of the user.
And those would happen in something
that's called a transaction,
which groups together multiple commands.
Atomicity refers to the notion
that either all of those commands
are going to succeed, or
they're all going to fail.
But we don't do part of it.
We don't have just updating the link and
not updating the user,
everything happens together.
So this is a nice property for
a database to have.
Consistency refers to the notion that
the database will always be consistent.
And to work from our Reddit example,
let's talk about this idea where we have
a link and a user who have properties.
If we have this notion that
a link has a score that gets
updated periodically, and the author or
the submitter of that link
also has a karma score that also
gets updated at the same time.
Consistency refers to the notion
that both the score and
the karma will be consistent
with one another, so
that we don't update the score
without also updating the karma.
Basically means the database will move
from one valid transaction to the next
so we'll never run a query that
gets a link's updated score but
can't also get the user's updated karma.
So isolation refers to the notion
that no transaction can interfere
with another.
So let's say we a link
that is both getting,
two votes coming at the same time
to increase the score of this link.
That means we're going to be updating
the link score up and down, and
the user's karma up and down.
And isolation refers to
the notion that this
upvote won't affect
the computation of this downvote.
If we were overriding this
link in our database,
it would be a shame if that downvote was
applied to the original link's score
before the upvote was applied.
Because the net score change
in here should be zero, but
it could be negative one if
these aren't handled properly.
So, isolation refers the notion
that each transaction cannot affect
other transactions.
Sometimes this is
accomplished through locking.
If two transactions affect the same row,
only one can go at a time,
and there are other ways of resolving
transaction and conflicts like that.
Isolation refers to a database's
ability to do that.
Finally, we have durability.
Durability refers to notion that
once a transaction is committed it
won't be lost.
This means that for example if we
send an update to our database and
we update some rows and
the database says okay successful.
That even if the database
is turned off or crashes or
is unplugged we won't lose that data.
That is durability.
One thing, I'd like you to know, I know
we introduced a lot of new concepts
in this portion here, but
the important takeaway from this,
is that when you're talking about
different database systems,
that you have different trade offs.
It's hard to be fully, have
a database that's completely atomic,
that's completely consistent.
All transactions are isolated and
is completely durable.
There is always some trade-offs.